[Música]
quando eu era menino
eu assisti a um filme é um filme de
terror que aconteceu num parque de
diversões e isso me deixou um pouco
impressionado
isso tem muito tempo por nos anos 80 mas
até hoje eu me recordo que tinha um
personagem lá era muito marcante
o filme se chamava pague para entrar
reze para sair
eu não imaginava que anos depois estaria
vendo esse filme de novo trabalhando no
judiciário
a diferença aqui na justiça brasileira
a gente não paga para entrar mas tem que
rezar pra sair
o brasil conta hoje com 79,7 milhões de
processos
se a gente pensar a nossa população
adulta e que em cada processo temos pelo
menos duas partes
todo mundo no brasil um processo
judicial
entra ano sai ano o número de processos
só aumenta
é essa estrutura de juízes e tribunais
gasta se cada vez mais dinheiro se nós
formos comparar enquanto japão noruega
gastão 0,06 por cento do seu pib com
judiciário o brasil gasta 1,4 por cento
do produto interno bruto hoje o que eu
vejo é que é muito fácil entrar na
justiça
o problema é sair dela é lógico nós
vamos ter ilhas de excelência obviamente
mas o processo em regra demora demais o
que eu pretendo mostrar é que os
labirintos do judiciário tem uma saída
por mais irracional que o nosso sistema
seja existem duas razões básicas pelas
quais o judiciário é usado em excesso
a primeira delas ele é o culpado
os grandes litigantes que utilizam para
protelar o cumprimento de obrigações e
para continuar prestando o mau serviço à
sociedade o poder público é o maior
usuário
dentre os 20 maiores litigantes existem
11 bancos duas companhias telefônicas
a segunda razão é que nós temos a
justiça grátis uma justiça a custo zero
nós temos no brasil 1.149 faculdade de
direito nos estados unidos com a
população 50% maior
são pouco mais de 200
todo ano formam-se 95 mil bacharéis de
direito arrumar advogado no brasil não é
difícil e o custo muito baixo
o pior é quando você arruma o advogado
estilo silvio santos
topa tudo por dinheiro isso prejudica e
muito você não tem um advogado vá ao
juizado especial
lá você não precisa de representação de
pagar taxas de ter conhecimento jurídico
é só bater na porta quero reclamar
pronto mais uma ação saindo do forno
isso não foi suficiente é só pedir
gratuidade de justiça
você alega que é pobre mesmo que não
seja que será considerado pobre custo
zero não paga nada mesmo se perder a
ação o que acontece com isso nós estamos
amontoado de demandas muitas ações
superficiais movidas por uma visão
oportunista misturadas com graves lesões
a direitos
os baixos custos e os baixos riscos de
se ligar no país fazem com que demandas
frívolas pipoca em diariamente no
judiciário até agora estava falando da
justiça cível porque a justiça criminal
é muito pior
eu tenho a impressão que o sistema de
justiça criminal foi construído para não
funcionar
eu me lembro quando eu estava em
michigan apresentado ao meu trabalho
para diversos pesquisadores do mundo
inteiro e eu tentava explicar como
funcionava
o sistema de justiça criminal no brasil
foi interessante que a palavra que eu
mais ouvi durante a minha apresentação
foi oa aí eu dizia por exemplo há aqui
no brasil o réu só pode ser preso depois
da condenação definitiva em razão da
pressão de inocência
eles disseram mas tem presunção de
inocência que nos estados unidos mas o
juiz condenou a sentença é mais do que
uma presunção não eu falei não
lá no brasil você tem que esperar o
trânsito em julgado mas com o tempo
demora o trânsito em julgado há só se
tiver um advogado razoável 10 15 anos
uai aí eu falava um empresário que
sonega e 10 milhões em impostos
se ele pagar a dívida o processo
criminal arquivado agora alguém furtou
um aparelho celular numa loja corre o
risco de ser preso mesmo que devolva o
aparelho e aí o advogado americano me
perguntou o que você faz no brasil
eu disse não eu sou é um juiz federal a
não ser que você faz
aí eu fui explicar pra ele que eu
julgava recursos no juizado especial
eu falei eu sou juiz de apelação do
smolka - corte que eles tenham aparecido
aqui nos estados unidos não tem juiz de
apelação o juiz resolveu a pequena causa
acabou o processo à parte quiser
recorrer
ela contrata um advogado vai pagar
outras taxas vai na justiça comum e
ninguém faz isso porque não vale a pena
eu fiz cara de paisagem
mudei o assunto porque eu fiquei com
vergonha de falar que depois que o jogo
processo ainda cabe recurso para a turma
regional para a turma nacional para o
stj e pelo supremo tribunal federal 6
instâncias para julgar pequenos crimes
pequenas causas
por fim falando de morosidade
eu disse para eles que o ministério da
justiça apurou que aqui no brasil crimes
de homicídio são julgados a contar da
data do crime
oito anos e seis meses depois então se
mataram seu pai sua mãe sua irmã seu
filho hoje o autor do crime vai ser
julgado em 2025 ou 2026
não falaram logo eles ficaram chocados
em silêncio e normalmente tem sido essa
a minha reação quando eu converso com
pessoas de outros países sobre o nosso
sistema de justiça fica em silêncio e
falar o que explicar o quê
como explicar essa irracionalidade do
nosso sistema
em resumo o sistema de justiça
só não fecha as portas porque os órgãos
públicos por mais deficientes que sejam
não estão sujeitos à falência
nós vivemos hoje um apagão judicial e as
pessoas não percebem ou se acostumaram é
natural aguardar cinco 10 15 122 anos
por uma resposta judicial
sim nós temos uma ação na justiça há 122
anos sem solução definitiva
e esse sentimento de conformismo e
resignação pra mim é assustador
talvez das trevas esteja certo o homem é
um ser que a tudo sabe tua
diante desse cenário parece que não há
saída
mas eu acredito que tem saída
eu tenho apostado minhas fichas na
implantação de um modelo de gestão
judicial a gestão processual é ba a
fronteira que teremos que desbravar se
quisermos melhorar a prestação do
serviço da justiça hoje
na turma recursal dos juizados especiais
eu tenho 200 processos para julgar
quando lá cheguei em 2013 eram seis mil
processos trabalhando muito e utilizando
técnicas de gestão eu praticamente dizer
ei o meu acervo
se me perguntarem a quanto tempo demora
uma ação na justiça
não sei mas no meu gabinete
um processo julgado em 30 dias mas eu
não quero falar de mim eu sou suspeito
pra isso vamos falar dos outros
em betim em minas gerais a 3ª vara
criminal da justiça estadual implantou o
modelo de gestão judicial
nesse ano em 2017 lá existem três varas
ea vara de betim
a 3ª vara é a que tem o maior volume de
processos ao menos em janeiro de 2017
então eu juntamente com luís pedrosa o
juiz da vara o henrique schvartsman é
escrivã juliana começamos a implantação
do modelo de gestão pela fase de
descongelamento
ou seja vamos mudar essa cultura em
vigor
submetemos um questionário aos
servidores estagiários para fazer um
diagnóstico da vara identificar
problemas
escolhemos uma estratégia de atuação que
é nosso objetivo de longo prazo pra
poder é fazer algo como metas ou seja e
esse objetivo era reduzir o acervo
introduzimos o conceito de indicadores
que média a prestação de serviço e de
metas que aquilo que tudo que todos
perseguem em fevereiro
nós iniciamos os quais de gestão
são reuniões mensais com a participação
de todos os servidores da vara eles
estão lá para discutir problemas e
apresentar é acompanhar resultados e
apresentar não conformidades
isso é interessante porque ninguém quer
ficar feio na fita
todos os servidores são chamados
apresenta o seu trabalho do mês em razão
disso eles se empenham se esforçam para
poder apresentar bons resultados
estabelece se um clima de cooperação em
sincronismo
em março nós passamos a abordar a
liderança nenhuma mudança será
implementada
se não existe um líder para conduzi la
quando o juiz é aprovado no concurso
público ele recebe o pacote básico
ele é o chefe se ele quiser
o upgrade
o pacote platinum para se tornar uma
idéia ele tem que suar bastante
e aí nós mostramos que o líder pode ser
autoritário democrático um professor um
delegado de tarefas
tudo vai depender da complexidade da
tarefa que executa e da capacidade do
liderado que vai executá-la
em abril nós abordamos eficiência e
eficácia
distinguimos empenho e desempenho perdas
e desperdícios
começamos a utilizar o mapeamento do
fluxo de trabalho
valendo-se da divisão do trabalho do
terrorismo da linha de produção de forte
do modelo toyota de melhoria contínua
tudo isso se aplica ao judiciário o
histograma o princípio de pareto eles
permitem você conhecer o acervo da
unidade judiciária e aí você consegue
estabelecer vias de tramitação mais
adequadas para cada uma das classes de
ações no mês seguinte nós abordamos a
gestão de pessoas é o nosso ativo mais
importante nós precisamos investir nas
pessoas e para isso para que elas se
tornem competentes é preciso que elas
adquiram habilidades e conhecimento
atitude é muito importante reforçar a
autoestima dos servidores para montar
uma equipe de alto desempenho
não é raro juízes reclamaram que não tem
servidores na sua vaga
eu logo retrucou ok embora pequena a sua
equipe já conta já alcançou o máximo
potencial de trabalho
eu sempre preferi trabalhar com um grupo
muito reduzido de pessoas altamente
eficientes do que um bando de cabeça de
bagre que bate cabeças nem todos pensam
assim
quando eu cheguei a montes claros na
vara federal havia 24 mil próprias
o inacreditável número de 49 estagiários
trabalhando na vara eo all ou seja
aquela velha mentalidade milhares de
processos precisamos de milhões de
pessoas para poder resolver
no mês seguinte nós começamos a tratar
da gestão do conhecimento
mostramos a importância de cada setor de
seu manual de trabalho é elaborado pelos
próprios servidores a fim de que possa
se entender o que é feito em cada área e
não só entender dentro da vara entender
o trabalho alheio
nós temos que força telecomunicações com
o ministério público delegacia de
polícia
a defensoria pública ou seja isso se
chama cuidar das interfaces
precisamos ter um diálogo consistente
que nos permite estabelecer rotinas
comuns que sejam objetivas simples e
resolutivas e tudo norteado por um
trabalho cooperativo
o juiz faz muito pouco
se não tiver o apoio das demais
instituições por fim chegando a julho em
julho nós reforçamos mais alguns
aspectos e sobretudo a necessidade de
estabelecer prazos máximos de duração de
processos
foi por isso que nós criamos o ct pj é
um programa elaborado pelo márcio
augusto de veneza e por mim que tem o
objetivo de controlar a tramitação dos
processos judiciais no judiciário nós
temos duas incertezas o que vem da
cabeça do juiz enquanto dá um tempo
demora pra ver se a gente começar a
estabelecer prazo se mudou o processo
estabelecendo prazos máximos dessa
duração nós vamos pelo menos trazer
menos imprevisibilidade
mas o importante foi trazer os
resultados colhidos e resultados que não
se resumiram a redução do acervo
processual houve economia de recursos
partes e advogados perceberam mais
rapidez na prestação do serviço
as pessoas estão trabalhando menos e
produzindo mais uma pesquisa de
satisfação que nós fizemos demonstrou
que todas essas respostas mereceram um
sonoro sim e esse sim significa que
precisamos mudar nosso olhar sobre o
judiciário abandonar as tradicionais
soluções de mais recursos mais juízes
mais servidores aquelas crença de que o
processo tem duração infinita de que
trabalhar na justiça só enxugar gelo
precisamos de outra crença a crença de
que devemos fazer tudo com excelência
usamos que eu tenho lutado nas
trincheiras da justiça me mostraram
claramente que é possível fazer isso é
possível fazer mais
é possível fazer melhor